hey guys people seem to enjoy watching
these 10 words or less videos so I
figured why not make another one only
this time review each individual fight
in Dragon Ball super in you guessed to
10 words or less now seeing as there is
room for misinterpretation here I
figured we should lay down some ground
rules for a fight to be considered a
fight it needs to be a physical
confrontation where at least two people
participate and know that they are
participating this rules out beerus
destroying worlds and things of that
nature these fights will also be rated
on a scale from -10 to 10 -10 being so
bad it's amazing and 10 just being
genuinely amazing So in theory the
closer a fight is to zero the worse it
is because it's just plain boring then
also scale and context will play a large
role in rating these individual fights
meaning a small comedic fight can still
be a 10 out of 10 if it's as good as it
can be it doesn't need to be an arc
ending Clash this video will cover every
fight up until the beginning of the
tournament of power as I figured that
alone is worth its own video in the
future special thanks to John apocalypse
again for the concept and without
further Ado let's review every fight in
Dragon Ball super in 10 words or less
incredible opening Clash I can feel the
hype not gonna lie given the context
this is surprisingly decent Majestic in
its terribleness it's the room of fight
scenes
you know it's rough when rock paper
scissors is better a
bleton we finally get a goodish fight
scene I mean it's uh well I mean yeah
but
the things they write to perpetuate
Hercules lie is hilarious insightful and
planted seeds for 100 episodes later
awesome see in episode 89 Tien man these
first hacks are rough to get through
[ __ ] this was just horrible I mean wow
hey look at skin you what why though
please Lord just get me to the freezer
fight
[Laughter]
actually decent arguably better than the
movie's version this was really lame
I've seen pigeons fight more
aggressively genuinely woke me up during
an otherwise boring episode Gohan why
must you tempt us with training first
match of the tournament and it's [ __ ]
Goku no okay that was really cool solid
enough fight sucks to see how irrelevant
Piccolo's now
Vegeta's gonna trash you Mr Roboto the
best fight Vegeta's had in a long time
fantastic ah the pecking order Goku
you're up incredibly important fight
that puts super back on the map supra's
got the best filler this was just fun go
nameless henchmen you can totally do it
really cool seeing Vegeta in the typical
hero role obligatory gotex Cameo way
better than it had any right to be one
of the best moments in the entire series
weirdly nostalgic seeing Goku stop that
sword with his fingers I love this fight
great animation great art and
captivating It's Not Easy Being Green
hey trunks try to land a punch sound
familiar anybody important scene that
shows cracks in zamasu's facade poor
Vegeta Goku black shouldn't be this
powerful already some of the best
animation in the series has ever seen
okay nice to see Goku get serious again
great scene given the hype after that
transformation this was majorly
disappointing okay that's more like it
much more exciting very much the
secondary fight in this episode yeah
that's right Vegeta destroy that black
guy wait what I mean I'm digging this
Arc but shit's getting weird father son
garlic gun was pretty cool gotta say
final Kamehameha the Geo blue somebody
Pinch Me powerful scene short but
spectacular oh God no please no stab I
enjoyed this way more than I probably
should have there's just something
Charming about this one innocent fun oh
beerus is gonna do the thing he did it
he did the thing holding out hope these
guys will eventually if I didn't expect
this to happen hell yeah Yep this
actually counts furry shoulders make me
uncomfortable first time they fall since
the Cell Games
so good brilliant unique and touching
interactions between Krillin and Goku
honestly better than I thought it'd be
oh damn Goku deflected that how take
progress hashtag fitfan great to see boo
fight again been way too long lavender's
John Cena
get it cause you can't see him and they
say every dog has his day not today
Justice for dash all right this is
pretty neat I gotta say and this was
[ __ ] awesome great animation for
19.99 you too can get Majin Buu's
instant ABS kinda wanted a better
introduction to dyspo genuinely awesome
to see Android 17 Again the best fight
in this Arc so far this is definitely a
thing that happens I actually like this
it was simple but decent a playful
amount of domestic abuse it took 88
episodes but Gohan is back sort of this
is the first time they fought since
Dragon Ball oh look Tien thinks he's
helping Let's ignore that Gohan got this
power in a day ironic Goku still doesn't
understand the gravity of this situation
Super Saiyan you say hold my beer Frieza
really puts the laughter in manslaughter
amazing visuals with limited animation
very pretty Ultra Instinct kuribo and
that's all of them up until the
tournament of power now I know none of
you guys out there want to sieve through
all of those to see what I thought the
best were so here are my top 5 favorite
fights in Dragon Ball super up until the
tournament of power top five number five
Goku vs Goku Black episode 50. as the
only fight set in present day with the
arcs antagonist this is Goku's first
encounter with Goku black its beautiful
color palette helps its Stand Out amidst
the dreary setting the rest of the arc
is set and has some of the best
animation this Series has seen up until
this point fantastic angles beautiful
choreography and standard animation this
is one fight scene that will be talked
about from now and into the future
number four Goku vs Hit episode 39
recognized by many as the moment Dragon
Ball super became awesome again this
fight truly lives up to that Legacy
being the last two fighters for their
respective universes the conclusion to
the tournament seemingly Falls onto
their shoulders coming packed with some
wonderful animation I'd be remiss not to
point out that this marked the series
return for the Kaioken technique also
it's one of my favorite moments in the
series and one I won't ever forget
number three golden Frieza versus the
Assassins episode 95. like many other
fans of Dragon Ball when the time came
to resurrect the emperor of the Universe
I was dreading it Frieza had been one of
my favorite characters in the show's
long history however moments from the
resurrection F Arc of super had served
to devalue and straight up destroy the
character in some cases however the
universe survival Arc episodes that
covered frieza's recruitment are some of
my favorites in the entire series never
have I seen a character handle so well
in super following the best Frieza
transformation in the series comes the
wonderfully Sinister destruction of
these pawns sent to assassinate the evil
emperor concluding with Frieza
overpowering a god of destruction's
energy blast it's a fantastic fight for
The Rebirth of a fantastic character bow
to the emperor number two Goku and
Trunks vs zamasu and black episode 57 so
there I was chilling out at my computer
watching that week's episode when
suddenly my jaw hits the floor out of
nowhere episode 57 delivers the absolute
best fight scene super had ever seen up
until this point crazy angles high-paced
action sequences evasive backhand
Springs fantastic effects animation this
really had it all and the funny thing is
it's very much buried in the middle of
this Arc with very little plump and
ceremony surrounding it so I wouldn't be
surprised if this whole scene went
unnoticed by some people skimming
through the series looking for the good
bits I couldn't recommend checking it
out more number one
fusamasu versus vegeto episode 66. for
some it could be a toss-up between
episode 57 and this as to which
delivered the best fight scene but this
isn't just about animation despite the
fight having tons of fantastic stuff
narratively speaking there is
significant tension in the air because
you know that this could very well be
the last chance to defeat zamasu it
provides us with the return of Vegito a
fan favorite character and introduces us
to a move I am sure will be in Dragon
Ball games for hundreds of years to come
the final Kamehameha breathtaking fight
but I'm sure you guys don't really care
about the best of something which means
I've gathered the worst of the worst
here as well that's right here are my
bottom 5 Dragon Ball super fight scenes
bottom five number five Future Trunks vs
Black and zamasu episode 62 following
arguably one of the most hype
transformations in the entire series of
Super Trunks combats both black and
zamasu it's stiff lifeless and truly
awful there's not much else I can say
about it except just look look at The
awfulness Melting on the screen Number
Four zamasu vs Zeno episode 6 seven
after what was easily the best Arc
Dragon Ball super had offered up thus
far came Zeno to ruin everything as they
were passing the Finish Line in one
scene Zeno destroys the entire point of
the arc thus making it entirely
pointless zamasu taking the form of the
sky is also a pretty dumb idea too it's
clear that these guys had no idea how to
finish this Arc the only thing that
would have been worse is if Goku
suddenly woke up on his way back from
the universe 6 tournament making this
all a dream number three Goku vs botamo
episode 33 speaking of the universe 6
tournament Arc let's talk about the
first fight offset tournament botamo vs
Goku this big yellow Abomination is the
eyesore of this Arc every other fight is
decent to great so this guy really left
the side down even his name is boring
and [ __ ] bowtamo I don't even want to
talk about him he's that damn boring and
you know what I'm not he's [ __ ] you all
know it moving on number two Goku vs
beerus episode 5. easily one of the most
infamous moments in the entire Series
history episode 5's confrontation
between beerus and Goku is truly a
difficult one to stomach it being years
removed since the scene's first ooze out
of our TV screens I actually sort of
find it funny now and I can still enjoy
some truly excellent cuts of Animation
within the fight also and other things
stopping it from taking the number one
spot is that it only took up a portion
of a single episode this scene is very
much the drunk uncle of the family that
you all know means well but [ __ ] up
right early it Charming in a way nothing
like the next one number one Goku vs
Frieza episodes 24 25 and 26. I think
it's fair to say that this is the worst
thing Dragon Ball has ever made now I'm
including GT in that there isn't a
single redeemable aspect to this fight
apart from a few seconds of animation
and even then that's pushing it it's
recapping a fight that was done 10 times
better in a movie it adds nothing to the
confrontation and clearly is from start
to finish going through the motions it's
an embarrassing and lazy blemish on an
otherwise legendary anime's Legacy this
fight is literally the worst
[Music]